foreign
[Music]
don't we but television sets today are
very different from the ones made 20
years ago yes the television sets then
had a box-like structure and were called
CRT television sets CRT stands for
cathode ray tube which was used to
display images on the screen
but did you know that cathode ray tubes
played a major role in the discovery of
subatomic particles
yes in 1897 JJ Thompson studied a
cathode discharge tube with a metal
plate fitted at either ends one of the
metal plates was connected to the
positive terminal of a battery it is
called the anode plate
the other was connected to the negative
Terminator of the battery and it is
called the cathode plate the battery was
used to produce high voltage inside the
tube a vacuum was created between the
two plates to reduce the pressure inside
the tube
when a high voltage was applied between
the two electrodes he observed a
greenish yellow fluorescence these are
cathode rays which travel from the
cathode terminal to the anode terminal
to study the properties of these cathode
rays JJ Thompson conducted a few
different tests in the same experimental
setup he applied an electric field
he observed that the Rays changed their
path under the influence of the electric
field
they showed deflection from the negative
charge this led to the conclusion that
the cathode rays consists of negatively
charged particles
these negatively charged particles were
later called electrons by g j Stoney
and that's how electrons were discovered
it was later found that the electrons
have a unit negative charge of magnitude
minus
1.602 multiplied by 10 raised to minus
19 coulombs whereas the mass of one
electron was equal to 1 over
1837 of the hydrogen atom how
interesting was that piece of scientific
history next time you watch something on
the television you'll remember how a
similar piece of equipment helped in the
discovery of electrons now time for you
to get back to your lesson see you next
time